and how long has writing been your
full-time job
I would say writing novels specifically
was probably only my full-time job for
about two years because
you know the the Indie author world it's
very dependent on output to the point
where you know when I say I write 2 000
words a day that actually would probably
be considered fairly slow you know for
most independent authors
um
you know there are people out there that
write five thousand words a day 10 000
words a day
um and I just didn't want to go that I
just didn't enjoy doing that you know
when I would work for that long or right
that long I wasn't uh I don't know the
the pain pleasure balance you know just
wasn't there for me so I started so I've
sort of Diversified my income streams a
little bit so I do receive income from
my books but I also do uh freelance
copywriting uh on the side
sometimes if a cool post soup gig comes
up I'll take that I recently post souped
a interactive movie that was really kind
of interesting to me on a technical
level
and I also have some screenplays that
have been optioned and that are being
shopped around so I mean I I sort of I
for me it worked best to kind of
diversify you know what I was doing I
think I mentioned this before but when
you are a full-time author and that is
your only income
it is a lot of pressure and I found that
although it was really cool and really
exciting when things were going well
when things weren't going well you know
it was it was again easy to get
discouraged if you're not careful and I
just found that that pressure
I didn't enjoy writing under those
conditions I actually enjoy writing more
now you know because it's not the only
thing I'm depending on
did you think that would be the case I
didn't I was really excited to go full
time with it and I was kind of surprised
when I realized uh that it it wasn't the
best fit for me but by the same token I
don't think I would ever
I would not I don't I have a hard time
imagining myself in sort of a typical
you know nine to five corporate job I
don't think I could go back to that most
of the things I do I'm very lucky that
they do still involve some element of
creativity I've also done like I said I
do Consulting with other authors and
I've done some creative Consulting on
screenplays
um so I still get to sort of exercise
those muscles but it just keeps it fresh
and it keeps like too much pressure from
going on the writing side
and when there is that pressure do you
find you're less creative or you're more
just stressed out and yeah I don't think
I was less creative because the work I
did during that time I still am happy
with but it just wasn't as much fun you
know it was it was just harder on me to
do it and also it's uh it's harder
you start to develop I'm sure you've
heard this from other people but it's
very easy to develop like an imposter
syndrome where
you know and I find this even more so
with novels where you know you're
working on it for so long and you're all
alone and nobody sees it you start to
wonder like well maybe I just got lucky
you know the first time you know or
maybe I just got lucky the first two
times like my fiance jokes that like
when I finish every book I always say
this is my worst book ever and she's
like you say that about all your books
you know but you just start to like
Wonder it's just hard to kind of keep
things in perspective I found for me so
I would just be much more hyper critical
on myself in in a non-constructive way
you know when when all I was doing was
writing the books and that was it I
would be uh super super critical and
hard on myself
that's interesting so it sounds like you
said there was sort of a confidence
issue when you first got here and then
you'd receive so many no's or you just
got to a point where it didn't bother
you as much and then it sounds like
there's this other point where when you
start and that's that's very interesting
to me there is but I mean I definitely
think that now having gone through all
that I
mentally I know like
just psyching yourself out that's not
true you know of course you've written
eight books like you're you have you
know all of them are rated very highly
so I can sort of talk myself off the
ledge but I definitely believe that
um once you do it she that's sort of
what I was saying like with the whole
Lottery thinking idea that oh when I do
this one thing like I've got it made
it's not really at least that's not the
way it felt for me you know because even
that one even this after the second book
which was enormously successful and
really allowed me to
do whatever I wanted for a couple years
you know after that but I still was
worried you know and I would write I
don't know if this is any good you know
like I mean it's I think it's just
it's just sort of in the back this voice
in the back of your head you just need
to learn to ignore it do the work and
then assess you know if it's good or bad
because until you're finished it's not
good or bad you know it's nothing until
it's done and even then you can go back
and edit it and prove it and work it
nothing comes out like perfect you know
it's it's you just have to do the work
and Trust in the work and then go back
and try to make it the best it can be
so it's not just if I get this many
downloads or this many purchases I'm
home free then there's this new pressure
not for me I mean I can only speak for
myself and you know some people may be
less critical of themselves some people
I think have different goals out of
publishing I mean I do think there are
authors out there that um probably just
look at it as a business you know I mean
they're authors who put out you know
like a book a week uh or hire ghost
writers you know and I'm not criticizing
their practices like it's it's almost
like I said when you're an author you're
also a publisher when you're an
independent author you're a publisher
and I think some people sort of
gravitate more to that publishing side
where it's a business and a product and
they have an assembly line that they and
they may or may not care very much about
the individual Products that come out I
don't know but uh for me you know I'm
very invested in the books I mean like I
said I want people to feel like they're
having this experience like they're
traveling to this location and you know
I've drawn on a lot of my own travels
and I always feel this sort of pressure
to capture the place you know in a fair
and believable light you know uh and so
for me I just found that um there was a
lot a lot of imposter syndrome like
after even after the first two books
which were really successful I would
always be like this isn't good enough or
I don't know if I can do it again you
know sure I did it two times three times
four times but can I do it again you
know that was always kind of hovering
over me
do people encourage you or discourage
you from putting the novella out for
free oh
um you know honestly I don't think I
really talked to anyone about it uh I um
I had like I said I had sort of done
research on what other authors had done
and I had seen that that had worked for
people and so I just did it but um
nobody I don't I really didn't tell
people a lot about what my sort of
long-term plan was at that point I kind
of kept my cards close to my chest
um in fact I remember at the time
the that company that I had done some
writing for you know when they found out
I was publishing books they're like oh
they must be a horror books you know
we'd love to see them I was like oh No
actually they're spy stuff you know like
because the writing I'd done from for
them was a horror based thing and they
knew I was a big horror fan so they were
really surprised that I had written
something totally you know different
um so yeah I I don't didn't don't think
people really chimed in on that one way
or the other
so once the the actual novel came out
you were able to leave your job yeah I
mean it sort of worked out um I didn't I
was a freelance post soup at that point
so really I just stopped you know
looking for gigs was what I did
um and I just focused on the next uh
next books and I did that for about two
years where that was the only income I
had coming in but like I said after two
years I did start to the I just felt
happier when I had other things you know
I still do a lot of writing and I still
put out books regularly but I didn't
want to have to put out you know four or
five six books a year like I wasn't
happy trying to do that
um and I did try you know the science
fiction series I wrote very quickly I
put out three books in one year and I
like those books but after that
experience I was like no I want to slow
it down a little bit you know so
have you ever done a book signing or
gone to read no because I mean I do sell
hard copies but mostly it's uh ebook
you know the and when you're when you're
an independent author I'd say ebooks are
going to be probably 90 of your sales
so Kindles and Kindle yeah I I had some
books that were wide some books that
were exclusive to Amazon it just depends
but that was most of the money also
audiobooks are starting to become bigger
but still I find most of my Revenue
comes from ebooks so did you read for
the audiobook no no I didn't I uh I
don't like my voice like I said so yeah
no but also I think uh to me that's a
skill you know there are professional
narrators like that's what they do sure
so I wanted to work with someone like
that you know that would really elevate
it had you ever really thought of what
the voice the actual voice of the
character was I did I mean I not in the
sense of I didn't put a lot of thought
into it but I certainly hear him in my
head I know what I think he sounds like
you know so I would listen to narrators
the first audiobooks actually weren't
independently produced they were with a
company license them from me
um so they had final say on who narrated
it but they did they sent me candidates
and I chimed in like oh I like this guy
I don't like this guy you know
interesting and so it's an American
accent yeah British okay he's American
wow and where did he grow up Kane yeah
it's it's a mystery it's a mystery open
so we know nothing yeah he's sort of a
cipher
um interest very little of his past has
been revealed and in fact there's sort
of a running joke in the books that
whenever someone is about to mention his
military record it says you know that
he's a veteran but it's never said like
where he served or what branch he served
and whenever someone's about to say it
like someone else always cuts them off
or someone says oh that's classified and
so readers will always sort of
offer their theories like oh he must
have been a Navy SEAL or he must have
been you know a marine Force Recon you
know but it's never been said like what
he was so does he give away any tells
with food that he might like or a phrase
I tried to it was the the intention of
the character was that he'd be
somewhat of a blank slate you know I
mean he's very I wanted there to be a
sort of an element of mystery almost
like he's almost like a force of nature
when he gets involved you know in
something so I mean he's he certainly
has traits you know he's very he's sort
of cynical he's someone who's been
betrayed and he's someone who has an
intense self-loathing because he you
know he looks back on the things he did
in the CIA in the army with regret you
know because he's seen now that not
everything was what he believed you know
that it was so he is very distrustful of
people that kind of elevate themselves
morally above others you know he's very
he's kind of bitter and cynical although
gradually through the books that sort of
changes you know he starts to kind of go
in this Redemptive Arc
um and he's you know he's he's someone
who's lived all around the world so he's
very uh open in terms of like what he'll
eat you know I mean the books are set
all different places and I always try to
I kind of try to present him as someone
that can sort of fit in almost anywhere
you know
um he drinks whiskey for the most part
and he doesn't like very sweet things
those are those are about the only two
things I can think of that are
consistent
is there a part of you that Wishes the
books would do better on Amazon so that
you wouldn't have to work anymore well I
mean like I said the work that I do is
is work I enjoy so it's still creative
kind of stuff so I mean I don't
of course I wish the books could be
number one New York Times bestsellers
you know I mean why not like of course I
would always want them no matter how
successful they are I think I would want
them more successful and they are
nowhere near you know that level of
success for sure but uh no I don't think
that I would want to only write books I
mean I I enjoy it it's a big part of
what I do but I would also want I mean
honestly I think what I would really
like would be the freedom to sort of
slow things down you know and write
fewer books that I could also write some
screenplays and maybe some TV pitches
and you know maybe uh you know do do the
author consulting which I really like I
like helping first-time authors and kind
of showing them you know the ropes and
what I did and kind of getting them
started on the right path
um because there's a lot of uh scams out
there and like predatory businesses that
kind of prey on first-time authors and
screenwriters I mean I'm sure you guys
have seen that kind of stuff so I you
know I when I do consult with authors
it's very inexpensive and I'm like don't
spend money on this like don't give
anyone ten thousand dollars to publish
your book you know don't do that you
know it's kind of steering them away
from the obvious scams so I enjoy doing
all that so I don't want to necessarily
give that stuff up but sure I mean who
doesn't want uh more success right
and when you work with these authors
they are ones that have have a finished
sometimes they do sometimes they're in
the middle you know sometimes they
haven't finished yet sometimes they've
written several books but they just
haven't been able to kind of achieve
success and they're not sure like what
they should be doing differently it's
kind of all over the map